this is from the Texan
Texas Supreme Court denies Jeff
younger's petition to keep children in
Texas in light of California trans
Refuge law
this is this is big
this is the guy who divorces his wife
he has a son the wife says the son is
trans and wants to be a girl and the dad
says that's not true the mom is just
saying that
there are other Witnesses who have
claimed that the kid wants to be a
little boy acts like a little boy but
whenever the mom comes around the kid
just does whatever the mom tells the kid
to do the mom is going to bring the kid
to California the dad sued saying
California has a non-extradition law I
think it just went into effect right now
right on the first
that says that if they chemically
castrate the law doesn't say chemically
castrated says gender
but if they provide gender affirming
medical surgeries or treatment to a
child they cannot be extradited by
another state who criminally charges
them so my question here is with all
this going on
I want you guys
you guys watching comment Super Chat
what do you think happens
when a child is taken from one state to
another state
Texas says it's illegal to do these
surgeries California says it's a it's a
it's illegal for the police to assist in
the extradition of a Doctor Who does
these surgeries what's going to happen
if this man's son is chemically
castrated and Texas says we're filing
criminal charges and California says
haha we don't care
not just we don't care but come here to
stay safe come and take him is what
they're going to say so the question I
have is
we are dealing with an extreme moral
issue a man's son I understand it's a
woman's son as well but the woman is the
one who took the kid if the man took the
kid and fled I would say a woman's child
is being taken from her a man's son is
being taken from him
and they are saying they will chemically
or potentially surgically castrate his
son
look
what scares me here is Texas will do
nothing California will smile the
federal government will threaten to
arrest him and Target his family but
what does a man do when his child is
taken away from him and they say they're
going to sterilize castrate
neuter whatever
like I think we're heading towards
really dangerous dangerous territory
Jeff needs a voice I think if you guys
are into it we should have him on the
show I don't know if the invitation's
ever been offered but I think before
that thing would happen at surgery or
some sort of happened to his child
against his will I would like to let him
speak out against it so people
understand what he's going through
I that's like I don't you have kids you
talk about that yeah I think about
I don't even have kids and I and I I'm
defensive about them like it's what what
a man do to protect his child
that's what that's that that this is
what I was talking about two scenarios
for a potential Civil War breakout and
Texas was was one was was the example in
both scenarios
a man and a woman are in a relationship
woman gets pregnant eight months later
she says you know what I've been talking
to my girlfriends I don't like this guy
I'm gonna break it off but this Baby's
bad news because it means we're in a
relationship for the rest for for 18
years at minimum and then we're always
going to see each other because of this
kid
I know I'll go to Colorado get an
abortion Texas says you can't do it you
can't abort a kid at eight months
Colorado says you can
is it kidnapping if the woman who's
eight months pregnant the baby is viable
goes to Colorado to have it terminated
what happened what happens if the if the
father says you know that that's that
that baby is viable she's gonna kill it
please stop them what happens
now that's that's a scenario where it's
kind of tough because there is a
distinction between a baby that's born
and a baby not born even if the baby has
was conceived at the exact same moment a
baby at eight months who is then
delivered prematurely and alive and the
woman kidnaps that baby and rushes to
Colorado that's kidnapping an attempted
murder and all that stuff but if the
baby's still in the womb the woman has a
right to literally destroy the babies by
kill it
then the other scenario is this
California's Sanctuary law for for
chemical castration and surgical genital
mutilation surgeries
what happens when Texas says that's
illegal you can't do it and the parent
kidnaps the child bringing them out of
state and then has the child castrated
is Texas going to send Troopers to
California no is the federal government
no
my fear then is that a posse will form
and you're going to see skirmishes and
militia action because I got to tell you
it's one thing when we argue about
antifa versus The Proud boys and there's
some nebulous ideological goal where a
guy is like America and other guys like
America is bad now we're gonna fight
yeah sure it's another thing when a guy
is like my son was taken from me I've
seen those Harrison Ford movies give me
back my son you know some dude's gonna
lose it and he's and his buddies are
going to go with them and they are going
to go kick doors in they should go to
the Supreme Court I would think the
federal government's supposed to step in
when there's cross state issues and then
this is definitely a Supreme Court case
in my opinion it went to the Texas
Supreme Court right and yeah and they
said no they voted in favor of the
mother he said he wanted to stop him
from going to California because then
she will get the she will basically
Texas ruled both parents have to sign
off on on you know this this surgery or
medical transition
so then the wife is like I'm gonna go to
California
and then he's like no don't let her do
it and they're like no she can't and
he's like but if she goes she's gonna
get the kid the surgery
and they're like whatever does the mama
have soul custody is that no but 50.
yeah but once so I I think yeah the way
it worked is that the court said both
parents have equal say but I don't know
exactly who has uh custody doesn't
necessarily mean how much time you get
with the kid so I don't know about that
the point is the moment she's in
California
Texas law is irrelevant to her and so is
this guy just going to be like oh woe is
me I lost myself this is like federal
law what is it federally can you
federally legally
get your kid castrated that's nuts I
mean like remember that story from
Loudoun County the his the guy his kid
was raped yep and no one was listening
to him all of his complaints were going
on deaf ears and so he showed up to the
schoolroom meeting and finally made a
fuss and then he got arrested there yep
they dragged him out so they dragged him
out that that famous video
it's definitely cult as the school was
covering up multiple and then we find
out assaults the physical assaults on on
you know children it's absolutely
certainly I want to clarify for you Ian
sorry guys uh in August 20 21 a Dallas
District Court granted his ex-wife full
custody but on October 2021 court order
agreed to by both parents states that
neither parent May treat a child with
hormonal suppression therapy puberty
blockers and or transgender reassignment
if and uh surgery if any without the
consent of the parents or court order
but California Senate Bill prohibits the
enforcement of an order based on another
State's law authorizing a child to be
removed from their parent based on that
parent or Guardian allowing a child to
receive gender affirming health care so
she's using her full custody to go under
the radar out of the state where she's
going to go where bypass this Texas law
and of course the left perspective is
this poor child the mother saving it
this is why I think it's cultural
Solutions like um hearing his voice like
you need tens and hundreds of thousands
of people wretching in horror at what
could happen to a small child because of
what and this is not the first time it
happened this happened in Canada as well
where a father was punished or even
talking to the media about a situation
where the state came in and said we're
going to transition your child he said
and a mother said we're going to
transition our child and he said no he
was arrested because he's spoken about
this it's crazy I made a tweet I said
how do you think humans would react to
finding out that not only are we not
alone in the universe but that we're
effectively livestock for an alien
species how would humans react to that
maybe the reason aliens haven't revealed
themselves to humans because humans are
more reasoning than say chickens so
that's what I was thinking about we got
chickens
we take the roosters out because the
roosters cause problems in chicken
Society roosters battle for dominance
and then get to bang all the chickens
and then they they pair up in in certain
numbers like one rooster will have like
six hens one will have eight but you
gotta have a good amount of hens for
each rooster otherwise they fight too
much but to the chickens this is normal
life we don't like their normal life I
don't like the roosters fighting no
human does so we remove one of the
roosters if they're a problem and they
won't stop playing by the rules and
right now Roberto Jr is king of that
chicken City with like 30 ladies we as
the people controlling the animals
dictate there's also
um what's it called like a capon or
something like that you can take the
rooster if you want for meat and you can
castrate it and then you get basically
chicken meat you know rooster meat's
tough you got to pressure cook it but if
you is that what it's called something
like that capons or chickens testicles
yes yeah so you take the rooster that
you cut open its back where it's it's
their inside and you remove them or you
whatever so I'm thinking about this and
it's like the state coming into someone
and saying we're taking your kids and
we're going to surgically alter them is
exactly like what we do to goats when
they tie the rubber band around the nuts
so they eventually fall off like we own
them they're livestock
now I don't think this is actually
anything to do with aliens it's that the
governments and the elites are treating
us like chickens like livestock did it
to Saddam Hussein I mean if they want
something and I don't know who they are
exactly but when people that are
attempting to control her yeah someone's
I think there's groups of people that
are trying to Vie for power they will
just you know go out you gotta wonder
when you have people going up on stage
at a TED Talk saying there's too many
people on this planet and we have to
reduce population growth what kind of
thing would they be willing to do if
they really believe this you guys saw
that Paul was Nam Ehrlich
the population bomb guy who keeps saying
there's too many people and then it
never turns out to be true yeah Jane
Goodall was just talking about it too
said all these problems would be avoided
if we had the population that we had 500
years ago which is just a bland generic
statement probably not totally accurate
yo indicating 500 million people about I
mean there is there is some truth to you
will own nothing and you will be happy
in that if you don't know you can't
regret not having it right like I can't
teleport I don't wake up crying that I
can't teleport I never could
I there are airplanes you can you can
buy a ticket day of get on a plane and
fly somewhere when when the when the
flights get canceled we get angry about
it you know so it's like if it so when
when I was flying for the holidays and
the plane gets canceled
I was just like dude I'm not gonna
scream and cry over like a busted plane
because the giant metal skybird someone
else like all of humanity is working
towards buildings like can't service me
in a single day where it's a luxury I
get it
but the idea of these Elites is that
take these things away from people
take away their knowledge of these
things and they won't be unhappy yeah
they're trying I'm thinking about that
with eating cockroaches and stuff the
bug narrative like if we ate meat
growing up so we know like if I had
grown up eating cockroaches fried and my
mom watching my mom do it I wouldn't
even think twice about eating
cockroaches and that we're the
generation where they're trying to
change I hate saying they it's so
generic but where you know economic
foreign
I'm just imagining these people
are chickens themselves thinking
everyone else are chickens and that
they're smarter chickens than the other
chickens I'm like dude you don't know
what you're talking about you think you
do you're wrong science changes what
Elon Musk talks about this we need more
people and he's right think about man
think about anything
there's a can of STEEZ over there I have
green tea I see Lucas drinking the can
was made by a canning company the the
printer ink or whatever is put onto the
can is made by a different company the
drink itself is made by a different
company it it takes such a tremendous
amount of specialty to make a single
item in this like let alone a phone I
mean the Plastics the metals the glass
all of the different specialties
requires experts in all of these
different fields
if the population of the planet dropped
to 500 million you would lose things
like you'd lose Plastics Cobalt you were
going to get your electrical vehicle
batteries oh no bro an electric car
couldn't exist on a population of 500
million people on this planet yeah I
just don't see it as being possible
electric cars are such complex machines
maybe some rudimentary kind of thing you
know you can get a handful of people but
who's going to mine the copper who's
going to then fashion the electric
motors who's going to generate the
energy all of the the more people we
have on the planet or I should say in
existence because we can leave the
Planet Too the more Specialties there
are the more we can do things to put it
very simply
when we talk about inventions and the
crazy things we have a levitating UFOs
in here right in front of Ian all that
really happens is some dude goes I
figured out how to how to make a thing
that will create magnetism if you put
electric current through it then someone
else goes hey I can buy those from you
and then put an axle in it and it'll
spin that axle and drive a wheel the
electric motor company is different from
the car company so basically what's
happening is tons of people are making
things that on their own are pointless
and then other people are connecting
things and making them do other things
less people means less technology I'll
put it much more simply
the Roman Empire had indoor plumbing
after the fall of the Roman Empire they
just didn't have it anymore so in in
Europe in the After the Dark Ages they
would just take dumps in Holes in the
Floor that would flop to the ground or
they would chuck them out the window in
buckets a thousand years after that's a
thousand years after they had indoor
plumbing in Rome A Thousand Years Later
they're like just forgot how to do it
yeah now imagine and that's not even
less people that's more people now
imagine what was in the Library of
Alexandria
um
again I I do I do believe that there was
kind of more advanced civilizations that
we don't know about but I think history
is just as fake as our news today and we
have to realize that the stories were
being told are being told for a very
specific reason a lot of the people that
are in charge a lot of them are
eugenicists a lot of them are
narcissists a lot of them are Control
Freaks and they're trying to get control
of every aspect of your life and we have
to remember the freedoms that we give up
today our grandchildren will never know
of tomorrow so I forgot who said that
someone else a lot smarter than me
actually said that but we're living in a
world where our freedoms are slowly and
surely just being taken away Technology
Innovation is is creeping into our
society and it's slowly eviscerating any
kind of anonymity any kind of privacy
any kind of uh secrecy that we
previously had before is gone we have
satellites we have cell phones we have
we have cameras we have facial
recognition watching everyone one of our
moves tracking our purchases tracking
where we're going tracking when we're
taking a dump we're truly moving towards
a society that is absolutely controlled
by these population control freaks and I
I think we're at a crossing point
especially right now I think right now
we're at a very crucial turning point in
world history especially when it comes
to the larger experiment that is the
United States and its larger freedoms
and it could either go total freedom
total slavery
um and I think that decision is going to
be made very soon I think it's going to
be made in 2023 to be honest with you
guys it's important to remember that
right now is all there is that time is
something humans made up to get places
at the same moment but it's always right
now and we are changing this right now
reality constantly so let that be some
motivation to get up there and move baby
that's my analysis what do you think
what's your analysis and assessment of
where we are as a society and where
we're moving forward
um I think culturally I'm really scared
for what's coming next just based on the
stuff that I've had to
to see uh through running running levels
of sex talk
um so yeah I mean
I mean I don't know I think
I I think that I would rather I'd rather
all the technology we have and live now
with all that even with all the
the the bad parts that comes with it
then to have lived hundreds of years ago
without what we have now
um so yeah I think we just have to be
more vigilant
with our online security
um
and yeah whenever whenever they talk
about eating the bugs I literally go on
a buy steak I'm like
I'm never gonna eat the bugs and I'm
just gonna eat steak hard but they're
implementing it in places like Australia
where a thousand schools are now forcing
their children uh to to eat the bugs
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time